abone ol
[Alkış]
biz Bir bedende doğruyoruz anne karnında
yumuşak korunaklı bir Havuzun içindeyken
Aynen ailemizi hissettiğimiz bir deneyim
yaşama gidiyoruz Elimizi yarısı yaşamak
çok da kolay değil birçok zorluğu
beraberinde getiriyor
o kendi hayatınızda kayıtlarımız var
kitlesel Hayır larımız var başka
canlılara dair kayıtlar var peki
bir yaşam
ve sürekli bu yenisini kabul ettiğimiz
bu önemli şekillerde hareket ettiğimiz
Sen kendini tekrar eden
farkında olmadan sürekli Birilerinin bir
şeylerin yarısını Tuttuğumuz bir doğum
günüymüş Tüm bu acı ve yokoluş
içerisinde nasıl çiçek açabiliriz ve tüm
bu acı ve yokoluşu içerisinde açan
çiçeği nasıl görebiliriz Ben kendim için
çiçeği görebildiğim yalan Yarattım
görmekte kalmıyorum bazen çiçeğe
dönüşüyorum bazen kokusuyla gerçek
oluyor
Selam bugün size bu alanların bahsetmek
istiyorum
O çok güzel olan şey de Bu alanın sadece
bana ait değil Herkese ait olması yani
gitmenin yollarını bulursak bu yer
hepimiz için tek başımıza da
erişebiliriz birlikte de
ayrıca başında söylediğim gibi bir
bedene doğruyoruz Ama bu yere gitmek
için nasıl bir bedel olduğumuzu da
hiçbir önemi yok ben burada kendimi
iyileştirdim gerçek dönüşürler yaşadım
başka insanların kendileriyle ilgili
deli keşiflerine Tanık olduğu bazen alan
açtım
ama ben kendi olurum yalnız kalma da
sorular sormakla ve hareket etmek ya
buldum
iyi geldiğini anlatmak için size biraz
asla bahsetmek istediğim şey
gel buraya nasıl geldim
abone ol
O benim doğduğum olan iyileşmek
üzerineydi ve
ama annem ve babam da olsa Hoş O yüzden
hastanede çok zaman geçirdim oranın
kokusu beyaz koridorları floresan
ışıkları birçok etkilerdi bu klinik
ortamın yanı sıra Doğada çok zaman
geçirdim
Şimdi mor manda Oynardım kumda çamurda
resim yapardım şiir yazardım parçamızı
küçükken yaptığı şeyler ama benim için
Duyanlar onlar da önemsiz limanları
onlar dışarı daha sonra ilkokul 5'te
babaannemle dedemin yanına
ilkokul okumaya gittiğimde bir kadını
aynı denmiş şimdi yer Yeni insanlar
kimseyi tanımıyorum Sanki o kimliğini O
kısmı değersiz leşmiş Tea iç boşalmıştı
tekrar Ben yaşa etmem gerekecekti yaptım
da dansın çok büyük etkisi oldu
dostluklarımız
Sen
benim için çok değerli olan bir
değiştiren dönüştüren
o kendi Benim değişti baktım ki ailem
görüştüm ben şunu da etkisi var
baktım ki aslında
ne olduğunu Cup genişledikçe Ben de
kabın içerisine geliştiği biliyorum yani
Samsun'dan Ankara'ya kim yer Ben de
buranın içerisine bir yiyebiliyorum
hareketlerimde bile biliyor bu sırada
bir dans yarışmasını kazandım Ben
kazandım yarışmayla dünyayı gezmeye
başladım yeni yerler gördüğümü tekrar bu
halin daha da büyüyebilir her şey daha
da büyük olabilir o zaman daha büyük
ayağa kalkabilirim geriye dönüp altında
onu fark ediyorum Aslında belki bir kere
daha kalın yiyebileceğiniz görmüş olmak
benim için daha büyük Hayaller kurmaya
yardımcı olmuştu 21 yaşında Londra'ya
taşındım okumak için sonra orada kaldım
ben zor bir yolculuk oldu
bu İzmir bakayım yaşadığımız sırada da
ve fark ettim yazmam 20 senedir
kuyruğunu kimdi bir kere daha
sıfırlanmış tık kimseyi tanımıyorum
yerdeyken yabancı buldum bir kediyim ve
dans ol kendime inşa ettiğim kişinin
obelion bile burada tam olarak çevirisi
yok o yüzden dedim ki iki daha deneyimiz
dansın ülkesinde ne var senin için daha
sonra Ötesinde ne var sorular sordum ya
zaten uzun çeken kendim konuşurdum soru
cevap verdi miyim şunu sordum kendime
için sen kimsin burada olmanın nasıl bir
önemi var
bu ne yapmam lazım ya da
bu fark ettim ki ben başka insanlara da
yardımcı olmak istiyorum yani daha sonra
dizisinde benim için bu vardı bu sıradan
serisini öğrendim dans elbisesi bir
yöntem bireylere terapisinin bekleyelim
sanatı dansı hareketi iletişim aracı
olarak kullandığı güvenliği alan
yarattığımız teke tekte grup olarak
çalışabilecek bilmeden oldu
çok
güzel bir Tanıdığım vardı hoşlanmıyorum
ezan anlamak tamam mı bunu kendime
söylemekten korkmam gelişimi dans erişte
bu sefer yeni ilgili yazılacaktı
Şimdi iyi 25 senesine iki paragrafta
özetlediği hayatımın son on senesine
gelecek olursa her şey birazcık daha
anlam kazanmaya başladı son geldiğim oda
içerisinde
bir bütün olduğumu hissediyorum daha
yakın olduğumu hissediyorum bütün olmaya
ve bu yerde öncekini tarz anlatmak
istiyorum klinik olarak çalışmaya
başladım otizmli çocuklarda şizofreni
tanısı olan yetişkinlerle
başka bir sürü sebepten toplum
tarafından
ötekileştirilmiş zorluklar yaşamış
insanlar da çalışma şansım oldu olmaya
devam ediyor
daha fazla şey öğreniyorum sürekli
Gelişmekte gereken bir alan Ama şunu
fark ettim ki sana aslında Sadece
estetiğini üretim olduğu yer değil
aslında duygularımızı
değiştirebileceğimiz ve başkalarına
duygularını dönüştürmeleri için alan
çekeceğimiz yer belirli insanlara ait
değil hepimiz için
bu mesela Savaş yüzünden ülkesini
kaybetmiş çocuklarla Ayakkabı
kutularının içerisine evler yaptığımızda
Sonra bunlardan bir şehir oluşturup
geriye dönüp baktığımızda
bu geçmişle gelecek arasında oldukları
yer ve bulundukları
Ya ben değersizlik üzerine konuşabilmek
benim için büyük kapılar açtı içinde
farklılığa yarattı ya da kelimeleri
kullanılmayan bir çocuklar haftada bir
aylarca yaptığımız çalışmaları üzerine
yarattığımız güvenli ortamda
bu onun bize güvenmiyor musun ve kendini
ifade etmeye başlaması iletişim Sadece
kelimelerle olmayacağını
gösterdim Ya da ben asla adam söylemem
dans etmem diyen birisinin hastanede
yaşadıklarını anlattıktan sonra ayağa
kalkıp dans edişini alan açmış olmak
onunla yaşamam bir sahnede binlerce
kişinin önünde dans etmekle benzer bir
sevdiği olmalı çıkartmayın içinde her
işimi de yaşadım ve deneyiminden
konuşuyorum çok farklı var oluş
şekilleri gibi görünüyor ama aslında
Özünde aynı şey var
yine aynı şey söylemek istiyorum Eğer
gözlerinizi kapayıp alanı Aşık kendinize
soruları sorarsanız sizin içinizden olsa
maç var bu
bu haberler olarak
Ha bir de o içindeki sanatçının bazı
soruları ve ve ifade etmek istediği
şeyler vardı o yüzden kendimde üretim şu
bu ve hayatı aslında bir şekilde
anlamaya çalıştım kendim için zorlandım
anlarda hayırların olduğunda bir şey
değil canım acıktığında hep sana da
kendimi
yükledim mesela orman yangınları
olduğundan şiir yazarak kendini
sakinleştir dim ormanda Sürekli
gidiyorum vermek istiyorsanız Herkese
çok tavsiye ederim düzenli oraya
gitmelisiniz bizim için çok iyi bir yer
da görüşmek ilgili kaygıların olduğunda
evler istediğim bir performans yaptığım
bu Engin'den ses kayıtları topladık ve
anlamaya çalıştık evlenirsin
bu kalbim kırıldığında kayıtlar
yaşadığım da belirli algıladım sonra bu
ağaçlardan heykeller yaptım
iki tane olduğumda kendimi tarihte
bağladım ve bu havada asılı kalma
hayattaki kaybolduğumuz yerle ilgili
hepimiz için bir şeyler söylemeye
çalıştım
bu yolun kaybettiğinde ve kararsız
kaldım da 28 gün boyunca bir oda
insanlara ne istiyorsun sorusunu sorduk
ağzımızdaki üzerindeki cevabı duvarları
astık
en son performansında ise Önüme Baktım
Ya ben işte
yaşadığımız kayıtlar yüzünden geçtim
senelerde etrafımızı öldür görüyorum
Ama bu araştırma sırasında karşıma sen
kilo Sevda şıksın seikilos
Aydın'da Bilmem öyle kasıtlı olarak
bulunmuş dünyanın bilinen en eski müzik
kompozisyonu ve Aydın'da bulunmuş
selam söyle şöyle hem sözleri var yani
melodisi var belediye şu an çalışacağım
ama sözleri şu şekilde
yaşarken
parlak hiçbir korkun olmasın Hayat Çok
Kısa bir süre için var ve zaman
alacağını alır
yani baktım ki
ben önüme bakıyorum ve benim karşıma
yaşanmışlığı Yok her seferinde her yere
baktığında kendini bir şekilde
dönüştürdü benim elimde şekil değişmiş
baştaki kabuk kaldı
ya o yüzden diyorum ki yaralarımıza
bakarsak
bu yarının Ötesinde ne var
bu çünkü bu yer öyle bir yer ki oradan
[Müzik]
ama buradan farklı şeyler var orası tam
olarak burası değil orada Barış Bir
Hayal değil biz daha birbirimize
benzeriz
abone ol
bu herşeyi kutulara koyarak anlamaya
çalışıyoruz yeni dünya düzeninde
birşeyleri kaza gelip kazaları ayırmak
bizim dünyaya alma Şeklimiz oldu
kendimize benzemeyen şefkatte
yaklaşıyoruz ayrılmıştık yalnız aştık
uzaklaştık bedenlerimiz arasında ciddi
mesafe girdim yüzümüzün yarısı görünmez
oldu
ne yuvalar ilişkiler evler dönüştü
Evet şimdi biz buraya tekrar bakmak
istersen bize söylemek istediğin başka
şeyler olabilir mi
O
benim yazmışım hareket dönüştürür
ben sana dönüştürür
Bu iletişimin farklı yolları vardır Bu
tekrar söylemek istiyorum sadece bana
veya bunu yapma seç insanlara ait değil
Herkese ait bir şey bunu kültürümüzde
geri getirmemiz gerektiğine inanıyorum
ve bunun için çalışıyorum Siz bu arada
çağırmak istiyorum zaman genişletmek
için
yaşadığını hissetmek Kendini özgür
hissetmek için
hayatım kutu sağlığını büyüsünü
hatırlamak için O uyuyor için daha senin
bu yaranıza Konuşuyorsun Onu paylaşın
inanıyorum ki sizin işinizde de yeni
Odalar geliyorlar yeni kapılar yeni
sorular açılacak çıkacak Belki de yeni
bir sen var Onun için altında
de babaannemin söylediğine göre ilk
konuşmayı öğrendiğim yıllarda
yazlıktaki ballı muzun aşağı sarktı
oradan geçenlere Sen kimsin Nereye
gidiyorsun diye sorar mı şım cevaplar
herhalde çok belirli şeylerdir bakkala
veya denize ihtimaller vardır bu çok
önemli değil ama soru önemli dedim ya
şimdi buradayım Kendime soruyorum iki
Sen kimsin Nereye gidiyorsun içinde çok
yoğun bir etmek isteği var
Bu yaşadığımız bu zorlukların kökündeki
Sevgi eksikliğini Şevkat eksikliğini
görüyorum bunu değiştirmek için
elimden geleni yapmaya çalışıyorum bir
şeyler üretip dünyaya gitmeye
çalışıyorum
ben bir iş gününün peşinden gidiyorum
bu sevgiyi almaya çalışıyorum Aslında
özünde
Evet şu an hatırlamanızı isterim Çünkü
bir soru gerçekten her şey
değiştirebiliriz
en uzun bir masada otururken birisini
söylediği şarkıyla gittiğimiz yer var ya
benim için tüm cevaplar tüm sorular
orada ya Dalga mı şans Erkan bir çocuğun
meraklı bana bakıp zorluklarından Peki
sen kimsin Nereye gidiyorsun teşekkürler
[Müzik]